one of the big questions every year is
whether or not one of the other three
teams not named the patriots in the afc
east can challenge a team that's had a
hammerlock on the division for years
well this year the starting quarterbacks
for the three teams not named the
patriots likely will all be
second year players guys who were taken
in the top 10 of the 2018 draft you've
got josh allen in buffalo sam darnold
with the jets and josh rosen the 10th
overall pick who was drafted by the
cardinals now traded the dolphins
assuming he beats out ryan fitzpatrick
for the starting job in miami three
second year guys and we've seen what
bill belichick does to young
quarterbacks and it it sets up as
another season of domination for the
patriots winning enough games so they
end up with a top seed so they end up
playing their home games in the
postseason and possibly end up back in
yet another super bowl it's going to
come down to whether or not these three
quarterbacks can really step it up and
challenge bill belichick's defense and
compete with the points that tom brady
the greatest quarterback of all time
will be able to score against the
buffalo jets and miami dolphins defenses
and not many people are expecting much
from the three contenders and the word
contender may be a stretch for those
three teams in the afc east but maybe
just maybe one of those teams is going
to
get lucky is going to string some wins
together is going to maybe shock the
patriots when they get a chance to play
them and maybe make it interesting if
for no reason other than to compete for
a wild card berth it will not be easy to
get a wild card spot it will be
incredibly difficult to challenge the
patriots for the division but these
young quarterbacks who
for all appearances will be the future
of those three franchises they may be
laying the foundation for an eventual
assault on the patriots it's it's not
likely to come this year but as this
year approaches one of the big stories
to watch is whether or not any of these
teams led by young quarterbacks is ready
to finally contend when it relates to
knocking off the new england patriots
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports